[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le vent souffle sur les plaines de la
bretagne à mujica juger tintin et son
garçon afin d'officiellement domaine a
tu me le dis tu t'en sors on est venu me
chercher d'oublier le décide il est mené
le combat à laval la route une mise en
scène de chez un guérisseur a pris de
grandes batailles se sont imposé en
maître
c'est vraiment très lents de défendre
notre terre et contre une armée semaine
après la grosse et de faire toute la
troupe s'est réunie autour de grand
menhir pour invoquer les dieux apprend
qu'il puisse nous bénir après s'être
brouillé avec mon frère est à 2 l mais
chaque nous donnerait à tous des caps et
d'hydromel pour le courage paquet de
file pour rester grand écart nous serons
dans la bataille cas c'est la première
fois que je pars en combat et j'espère
être digne de la tribu de tallard est-ce
que vous exercez soir
[Applaudissements]
et
ah la la
à
j'ai pu en temps
avec le monde
non
[Musique]
les gens
fait quelques incantations de tuiles et
de magie il attribue le vent ne courrait
vers l'ennemi des ivg de royallieu
maison franchement les mémés qui
revenait toujours aux gens non nous fait
tomber en arrêt devant mon regard sous
le poids des reins que possible qui sait
pas pas d'élan des lâches et des épis
dans les jardins lesquels qui coule et
distancent la verte de la mer comme
séjour de près le pôle home se traîne à
la limite du malaise de la haye la
politique continue à ces convois dit
jean pierre tu mets telle était la
fierté les taux de la tribu la lutte à
continuer comme ça jusqu'au soleil
couchant at on fait aussi des
traitements plus d'acharnement mais pour
la vie de leurs ancêtres enterrés là et
pour que toutes les lois de la tribu de
dana
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai vu un temps
le dana
des chants de guerre
voilà
m
[Musique]
nana
nous marquons
[Applaudissements]
les héros sont magnifiques et je les
adore je les adore je les ai vus dans ce
vol nous vos excuses parce que vous
étiez passé après sur l'after et j'ai
dit je les veux dans tpm p ça fait 15
jours que je demande un quinze chevaux
on peut sonner hamid aurais tu vont pas
[Applaudissements]